one we'll do with that and we'll see if
we're out there
going live out there into the impossible
with a very very special guest
this is bill pulte who is the twitter
philanthropist extraordinaire a
fascinating character
he has inspired me to uh to do something
which i've never really done before or
thought about doing
how i could help people how i could uh
live vicariously through the young
people that i seek to influence
this is one of my jobs my my goal in
life is to
inspire a million minds to always be
curious bill
abc in the business world always be
closing no it's uh
it stands for always be curious so how
are you doing today in florida
i'm doing great happy to be here thanks
i've been
following your work now for a little
while and uh
it's pretty cool stuff you did
well likewise i i i really uh respected
uh look up to what you do and and
the infectious enthusiasm that you have
uh for making the world a better place
and the place that i wanted to start
with
is uh is is you know how you got this
epic mission to affect millions of
people worldwide and i'm trying to
emulate at the end of today's uh
live stream i'm going to give away uh to
a lucky science teacher a hundred
dollars via
via cash apps uh emulating you how you
do it so effectively
i'm just trying to be like everybody try
to get his money and everybody who's
listening
yeah so go on twitter tweet me your
favorite idea for
a scientific teaching tool it could be a
microscope telescope petri did whatever
you think
of something creative i'll select it
live and bill
uh and i will uh choose the winner and
we'll tweet it out and i'll send you a
hundred bucks via cash
uh but bill how did you get started with
this epic mission
well i basically had the idea to give
away money on the internet i don't know
really where i came from but as you know
there's when you have a good idea it
just kind of hits like lightning and you
just say oh my god you know maybe i
should try this thing out so
people originally thought i was crazy
for giving away money people actually
some of my friends
sent me messages and they would say hey
did your account get hacked
because it's claiming to give away money
on twitter and it just didn't make any
sense
and it really began a movement i would
say of
of giving money uh to people
on the internet and you see it now it's
widespread all over twitter i mean
obviously there's
there's scams and people trying to scam
people out of money and
all this kind of stuff but scams have
been going on forever whether it's with
mail fraud or
people robbing banks or whatever it's
just now we have technology and so
people are now
able to send money to each other
obviously there's consequences that come
with that
but it's really become brian a a very
viral movement and uh we couldn't be
happier with the success that we've had
i mean it's it's
exceeded my wildest expectations
and tell me about your your upbringing
tell me about you know your story what's
your origin story you know i'm a
cosmologist i talk about the origin of
the universe
the passion that i have the curiosity
that i have what what are you most
curious about what were you like as a
young person that
you know you're doing something so
unusual what were you like as a kid that
brought you to where you are now
um well i didn't really understand the
power of giving until
i was uh older and until i had money and
even then it was weird because when you
when you have money as you probably know
um you know you got the money by saying
how do i get
money and how do i keep money for myself
and so it's a little bit
counterintuitive you know okay i've been
working to get money for myself and for
my family and now i have the ability to
give it to people so
i think that that was something that was
learned and i learned that from
frankly my grandfather who was a very
generous guy
and um you know i didn't really learn it
until an older age i wish
i mean i was i like to think that i was
always kind and nice and giving when i
was young but
um you know really once i had resources
and stuff that i start to
to give to people yeah i mean i i like
to think when people say
you know for me personally there's a
religious commandment for me as a
practicing jew
it's a commandment to give away 10 but
there's also a maximum component and i
wonder sometimes i i think about you
bill
and i and i worry like can you do too
much uh not to like be too flattering or
too egotistical
but you know there's a commandment that
you shouldn't give more than 20
away uh in the bible in the torah the
old testament
because there's a certain sense that you
could get too full of yourself like
you're doing too much like
leave room for god and i'm not i'm not
going to proselytize i never do that
it's actually forbidden in judaism to
process
but i want to ask you like is there a
danger you could do too much and and
start to think that like
you know it depends on you too much i
actually say that twitter philanthropy
will never be successful so long as it
is dependent on me
and what i try to do basically is try to
get
other people to donate and help people
who are in critical need i mean
nothing would make me happier frankly
than to
turn my account in like incognito mode
and just
watch everybody take care of each other
and that really happens i mean if you
see
on twitter now you'll often see somebody
who's struggling with cancer or
really having a hard time and people
will find that person
and you know nine times out to ten if
they're really hurting
somebody's gonna come and give them
money and take care of them so
um to me that is central to my mission
is removing
myself from me uh from from twitter
philanthropy and making it sustainable
above and beyond me so we'll see it's
gonna it's gonna take some time and i
think you know we continue to make
progress
um with you know just the amount of
people that are getting involved with
twitter philanthropy i mean brian i
don't know if you know but our average
donation is about 14
and this is from people from all across
the globe so when i posted like
yesterday i think there was a
four-year-old who had
cancer and boom i put it up four minutes
later you know her whole family's rent
and travel i think was
paid for so when you think about the
challenges that
that are inevitable the hurdles that you
face you know what what kinds of uh
barriers or challenges are still facing
you and what you know have have been the
surprising
you know uh hurdles that you've overcome
that you might have thought would be
un unrecoverable or impossible as we say
in the
impossible podcast but because you
overcame them you know you you're sort
of
on the other side yeah and you can hear
me right because it's cracking up on my
side
yeah it was a little bit crackly for a
second right yeah yeah um
so can you say the last part of the
question i'm sorry oh i was gonna say
what
what challenges you know did you
anticipate you know in the beginning of
of your mission
oh it's still like really noisy is there
like a keyboard or is that is that
you think you know what's uh causing
that i'm not sure with that
i got a strong internet too so today
um i wonder what that sounds like you
want me to
start yeah maybe let me um let me take
you
out and i'll try to put you back in the
room let me see here
uh i can take you off of here let's see
how about that no uh and now
let's see okay now he's out of the room
let's see if he'll come back in
i'm talking with bill pulte the uh
innovator behind twitter philanthropy
who's giving away
millions uh of dollars to help millions
of people
in a mission to make the world a better
place and he's inspired me
at the end of this live stream we're
going to give away a hundred dollars to
a teacher
because i believe teachers change the
world more than any other individual
let's see if he is there hey belle can
you hear me
yeah i can hear you greg okay that's
better now yeah so
i don't know i was asking about
challenges and so
inevitably a challenge you know makes
someone stronger uh but
have there been um you know kind of more
challenges uh than you expected or
has it been kind of you know getting
easier with time or is it getting harder
with time
how have been the you know barriers to
your mission um
how have they been progressing yeah i
would say that it just continues to get
easier and easier and easier
um in terms of doing it because i'm
getting more fluency you know
my family's background was in housing
and my background was in housing
supplies so
you know that's really my expertise that
in business
and so i'm i'm starting to understand
more the viral network and the viral
capabilities of
how to get things to go viral but viral
in a way where especially you can
help people and raise a lot of money and
those type of things
it just continues to get easier and
easier and god willing it will keep
doing that
so people in the chat room are saying
that you're they're idle
they want to make money to give it away
and you talked about um
at one point you know sam walton was an
idol you know
of of yours he you know kind of
prototypical founder of walmart
you know made made tons of money but we
also see that there are you know kind of
vilifications that people have of people
that make great wealth
in your opinion what is the purpose of
wealth what what can wealth be good for
can it be
used for for purposes that aren't so
pure what is the purpose and the meaning
of wealth to you bill
it's a great question um from my
perspective money is just resources
and resources to do what whatever
somebody wishes
you know somebody says oh you know money
is the root of all evil and there may
very well be truth to that
but in the hands of the right person the
right people i think that money can be a
great uh
influence and instead of relying on the
government to your point you know
this fancy word called philanthropist i
think is just
somebody who has money who has you know
resources you can put whatever label you
want on it
and those people are the people in my
opinion who've figured out a way to get
money and in many cases can do things
more efficiently than the government
i mean for example my background was in
business and so
when i looked at twitter philanthropy i
didn't look at it in terms of anything
other than
okay why is commerce not being done
through technology we have amazon.com we
have google we have these other things
so why not
why not reinvent charity with with
technology and i think that that's
really what is the big story
of what we've done is uh using
technology for good
and uh i think that sometimes you can
call it philanthropist you can put
whatever label you want on it but
sometimes business people
or people who've you know innovated um
can bring innovation to something um and
and it really helps people and i i'd
like to think that's what we've done now
i mean
we've really brought we're bringing
charity in the 21st century i say
um by what we're doing on twitter you
know no no more and i love corporate
over
i love i love uh you know charitable
overheads and charitable dinners and
lord knows you and me been to a lot of
those things
but this totally gets rid of all the
guts of
all that cost and just connects it
peer-to-peer
yeah that's the innova that's a
decentralized uh
philanthropy so i i call it d5 phi
and speaking of government people in the
chat room are saying
polti 2024 can you say anything about
those rumors bill
no you're too young to be president
right
uh i guess so you have to be what 35
percent 35
yeah a couple more years you'll be there
my friend um
talk to me about it not happening you're
not happening okay yeah he denies
those rumors right now we got people
from all different backgrounds
um and so i want to talk about education
do you have an educator or somebody that
that
taught you uh you know maybe and finance
maybe in philanthropy
uh because i am an educator and that is
an awesome responsibility and i'll just
tell you
as i say often the word scientists in
the russian language
uh and russians are some of the best
scientists in in history that means
someone who was taught
it doesn't mean you know that you came
from a special background it just means
you were taught
to me that means you have an obligation
to give back and you have to become a
teacher
i feel like i have to teach and i have
to give back and if i can give back
financially too
so be what what did the teacher teach
you what what lessons you take away from
great teachers in your life
well it's funny you ask that because
what i try to do is not just give my
money online but is to
inspire other people to give online but
frankly the root of what i'm trying to
do is teach people how to help
themselves and so
in many ways i think that you know that
is really you know
it's like uh i think it was uh i forget
the exact part of the bible but
um you know where uh they said you know
teach
uh somebody how to fish instead of just
giving them fish
all right so for a lifetime so so yeah
there you know there are definitely
people who have educated me
um but i wouldn't say that in in
philanthropy it's really been from the
academic world uh it was more from my
grandfather who taught me
you know uh that really to give is to
receive
and that people can get a lot of
happiness
counterintuitively by by giving away
stuff and um you know if ever i'm having
a tough day or if i'm
you know busy working or something like
that and i just want a breather
you know there's nothing better than
getting online and finding somebody
who's really got it bad
and taking care of them so you know i'm
not here to say oh i'm doing this
because you know i'm a good guy or
anything like that in fact i tell people
don't tell me that because it's
not good for anybody's psychology and
number two is
i'm i'm doing it in a way selfishly and
i believe it's kind of like when you're
on an airplane
and and they're saying things about like
you know how you need to get your take
the oxygen mask before you help others
i mean that's that's kind of the way i
view even charity is
you know uh it's all right to be selfish
in my opinion when you give
yeah yeah exactly that's right yeah
there's a kind of virtue and
taking care of other people that you
benefit yourself it's the one thing that
giving away
makes you richer and and i think you
know people are saying in the chat room
we got hundreds of people leave a thumbs
up if you're enjoying this live stream
if you like bill's epic mission
if you uh if you've learned from bill if
you've been inspired by bill
to give in your own way you look 10 you
can give 10 if you have a dollar you can
give 10
uh no matter what you give 10 if you
have nothing you have 10 if you have
your time uh we have that clicking sound
again bill i don't know if you want to
jump back in again i'll put you out and
then maybe you want to walk back
sure yeah yeah i'll try that one more
time uh just a reminder we've got uh
people
tuning in from around the world and this
is really epic i've never had so many
people from around the world
i do ask you to subscribe to the channel
if you're new here we talk
to the greatest minds in human history
i've had three billionaires nine nobel
prize winners
an astronaut while she was live aboard
the international space station
we do these live streams quite
frequently and uh we just really
love to connect a million minds in a
multiverse
of the world's greatest talent and the
world's greatest inspiring figures of
which bill is one
uh bill we're getting comments and
questions from people from kenya
from uh from the middle east from all
over the world it's so amazing
the things that you do so if you've been
inspired by bill leave a thumbs up
leave a comment let me know your
question if a teacher made something
um did something for you in any case
um so then the last thing i want to say
is is this
uh has twitter reached out to you have
you been you know contacted by twitter
you're kind of doing some
some marvelous you know public relations
for twitter have they been supportive of
your mission
they have been and i've spoken with a
few of the executives there i think they
really like it i think
one of the things that they like is that
um
number one success but i think
you know i don't want to speak for them
but i think that they really like the
organic nature of it in other words
you know this is not something that was
paid by a corporation
or this is not something this is not
some kind of ad campaign or
something phony right this is this is
straight from you know people wanting to
help other people out
and um and it's a very viral movement
it's just people wanting to take care of
people and so i think when they see that
when they see the photos of the people
with cancer
getting help and you know these other
things as i've understood from them they
they very very much enjoy it and
encourage it
that's really wonderful and then uh you
chose twitter of course you could have
chosen any of the
uh different different uh social media
platforms
uh of course the other thing that
fascinates me you've gotten interested
in in cryptocurrency you've
expressed support for past guests that
i've had on my show
uh such as michael saylor and and other
folks
um what is that what do you like about
that um uh
cryptocurrency as a modality not
necessarily has to be related to
philanthropy but what does it mean it is
related to philanthropy yeah tell me
about it's very much related to
philanthropy
and i think that you know one of the
things that people are because i get
questions all the time about
cryptocurrency and why i'm
in a fave in favor of it and stuff and
i think that bitcoin is really
empowering the individual it's really
about you know
the individual person taking control of
their own destiny and you know you have
the government who
you know lord knows is political and all
these people do is fight and they hate
each other
and all this crap and bitcoin kind of
cuts out
all that crap and i think that bitcoin
frankly can be a huge
engine for you know as i said it's a
fancy label
uh called philanthropy um but and i like
the word but i just i think sometimes
you make it too complicated you know and
and so bitcoin i think pierces through
the philanthropy label
and if we can get bitcoin to more people
um
they as individuals can be empowered and
i think that
you know an empowered individual is is a
very very strong force
and i think and individuals can actually
take care of each other
in a very viral way and we're seeing
that with twitter and
i i would predict brian if we're sitting
here 10 20 years from now and we're
doing an interview which hopefully you
and i are we're around for a long time
um i would predict in 10 or 20 years
you're going to see
peer-to-peer people helping each other
people lending
each other money to each other of course
all legally but in a way that
gets at acute needs because this whole
idea of waiting for
bureaucratic uh paper-oriented
government systems to go and help people
is just
so 18th century and i
i would expect that the 21st century
really
starts to pick up steam absolutely okay
bill
we're reaching slowly to the end of the
live stream before i have to teach my
students about cosmology in the universe
but before we do i just want to remind
people to please follow bill on twitter
and follow
his epic mission i'm also on twitter at
dr brian keating
and on youtube dr brian kenny please
subscribe everybody
yes please do i can use it i can use the
fans because i want to emulate bill and
the science community i want to be the
bill pulte of the science philanthropy
community to
inspire a million minds to learn about
science because if we're ever going to
become interplanetary intergalactic
we're going to need a million scientific
minds to be funded
and and educated uh bill just the same
way and we can do that with bits and
bytes as well
and but we need funding to do that as
well and i'm hoping to emulate you as
much as possible
i ask all my guests who treasure i
treasure so much i've done it with
billionaires i've done it with nobel
prize winners i want to do it with you
uh and a quick rundown of what i call
the thrilling three questions these are
existential questions then we'll give
away a hundred dollars to the winner
of the uh science twitter giveaway and
that is i want to ask you three
questions which is what do you want when
you reach the biblical age of 120 years
old
what do you want to leave as a bit of
ethical wisdom or wisdom that you've
learned in general
not monetary but purely wisdom for
future generations to know
what is most important to you that a
future generation should know
just to give us to receive and to not be
uh
worried about it being selfish because
uh actually in some ways being selfish
can actually be a great gift to other
people so
to give us to receive and don't worry
about doing it for purposes of
uh you know wanting to feel good about
yourself things can be a win-win charity
doesn't need to be a zero-sum game
okay wonderful next question i have is
uh
about fair yeah that's wonderful i love
it the next one has to do with
uh with going into the future as well
and that is if you could have a time
capsule
that would last for a billion years and
could kind of represent
the pinnacle of what humankind has
achieved or could achieve
uh to kind of tell aliens uh about what
we achieved on earth
what kind of represents to you the
greatest accomplishment of
all of humankind that's a great question
um
i would have to say the
at least you know from my vantage point
the invention of the internet
and the invention of uh being able to
have deflation
you know back in the 1970s for example
and who knows we may have inflation in
the coming months and stuff like that
but
uh generally speaking i think that
technology has been very
deflating for for prices and i think
that that has actually lifted a lot of
people
out of poverty or at least made uh
progress
uh for people easier to obtain so i
think that's probably the best thing
that we've done is use technology
whether it's amazon
or or what have you to uh really make
things
more affordable for people so more
people can be
lifted out of poverty that's awesome
great and then the final question that i
ask all of my uh treasured guests who
honor me with their presence on this
show
uh has to do with the past so usually
i'm asking 80 year old nobel prize
winners or billionaires like jim simons
or whatever but
yeah sorry i'm none of those yeah i want
to ask you
uh what happened well you know the first
billion is the hardest they tell me the
first nobel prize is the hardest bill so
don't worry you got plenty of time
but i want to ask you um as a 20 year
old or a 15 year old
you're so young um what what mysterious
aspect of life
perplexed you but thanks to your courage
uh
you had the courage to go into the
impossible that's the title of my
podcast it's a quote from
from arthur c clarke who said the only
way of knowing
the limits of the possible is to go
beyond them
into the impossible that's how i chose
the name of this podcast so i want to
ask you what seemed impossible to you as
a 20 year old
that now seems possible i think you had
the courage to go into the impossible
i think that uh i love the name anything
in the impossible because i think
that that name anything in the
impossible right a lot of other people
would have said even when we started
giving away money on twitter oh that's
impossible what the hell are you doing
doing that that's crazy
talk you shouldn't be giving away money
it's impossible um
so i think that that is uh that that
that is a huge one
is you know not seeing limits and
there's no such word as can't
thinking outside the box but in terms of
you know my own life and past like you
were asking is
like i think you know and look i don't
i'm not gonna sit here and say i'm fine
with death obviously who wants to die
but uh i think that you know confronting
death and confronting our own mortality
in a certain way too
that has helped really crystallize uh my
thoughts on charity because
you know at the end of the day all of
our clocks are going to run out and so
i think death is the great equalizer and
uh
you know at least that's helped me quite
a bit uh punch through things that
i would normally think were impossible
but death has a way of certainly uh
you know in god obviously um and you
know you could argue
those two things are related um you know
that
has helped me punch through things that
i believe to be impossible
um wonderful bill you're you're so deep
and uh you're a modern-day philosopher
yourself i want to thank you for going
into the impact i don't know about that
what you just said really uh echoes the
uh the words of audrey hepburn the great
actor she said
nothing is impossible the very word
itself says
i'm possible i'm possible never forget
that
bill okay we're ready to give away a
hundred dollars to one of my
subscribers so please subscribe to bill
and subscribe to me let's get bill to
three million subscribers he needs it
badly
he's only a couple of thousand away mr
kyle grant at mr kyle grant
he subscribed and he has uh
requested a telescope so that was my
first
uh scientific instrument he sent me a
suggestion that we should get a
telescope as a scientific instrument so
that
is the man who won the teacher that won
the
uh the science twitter giveaway so
congratulations to kyle grant
uh that was my first scientific
instrument i will send it to him
via cash and uh i'm now connected to him
thank you bill for
for really inspiring me inspiring
millions of people around the world
i can't thank you enough i hope you'll
come back and uh and we'll do this again
maybe we'll make this a tradition and
and
and really from the bottom my heart i
hope we meet in person someday my friend
that would be great i would enjoy it and
uh my wife is a chemical engineer so she
would
love to speak with you about everything
that you're doing so phenomenal oh thank
you
end up being you and her talking i would
love it and
that would be a treat for me bill pulte
thank you so much uh subscribe to him
find out about his epic mission
uh and and contribute whatever way you
can out there
and uh and please join uh my mission to
inspire a million minds and the
multiverse to
to always be curious abc that's the
mission of my life
to teach and to be well out there in our
beautiful beautiful cosmos and for now
i'm signing off
subscribe to the channel for videos and
interviews with billionaires brainiacs
and a host of the world's greatest minds
it's a privilege it's an honor i'm so
happy to share
my life and my curiosity with great
intellects and the greatest minds in
history so i want to thank you for
sharing
this incredibly rapid brief amount of
time
with me before i go teach my children
not children some of them are
adults now but i get to teach at uc san
diego where i
am uh the co-associate director of the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination check me out
dr brian keating give me a comment let
me know what you thought of this
if you'd like me to do it again i i will
certainly
try to raise another hundred dollars
from my piggy bank and uh
and try to support more great teachers
out there
for now look at my playlist and enjoy
some of the great interviews i've done
there's one with jim simons i'll put a
link
in the cards over here jim simon's a
great philanthropist michael saylor i'm
hoping to have ray dalio on the show
uh very soon talk about his epic
missions and his advice
as a human being as a philanthropist as
a father
and as a uh as a true as a true
philosopher as well so with that i bid
you
a wonderful rest of your day in this
wonderful planet
and i wish you blessings wherever you
are i treasure my audience
and uh and i thank you for going into
the impossible with me yours truly dr
brian keating bye everybody thank you so
much and i'll
end with an outro my good good friend
miguel
who is expecting with his wife sometime
coming up later out of the impossible
into the impossible
i hope he's gonna be as blessed as i am
as
as some of you are to have children in
our lives
you